- [Kelly] Do you do anything outdoorsy?
- No, come on, no.
- [Kelly] No?
- Yes, you did the triathlon!
- Yeah, I go out-
- That's outdoors!
- And you swim in the ocean.
- [Max] I go outside.
- Wait, what in the world?
That was a lie.
Your answer was a lie.
- I go outside.
- [Kelly] Okay, yeah, you're outdoorsy.
- (laughs) Yeah, if that's
what that means, sure.
(audience laughs)
- I- That's super outdoorsy.
You being outdoors in an extended amount
of period to conquer that.
- And you almost drowned.
- [Max] It was a couple hours.
- You almost drowned?
- Yes. (chuckles)
- Um, I did almost drown.
There was- (laughs)
- What?
- [Max] We were-
- Don't you have to sign something?
I have to sign things with production
that you're not allowed to die.
- [Beth] Yes!
I just, I ignore it.
I tell them that I'm
just gonna go for a walk.
Um, I told this, I- there was a woman
who I did the triathlon
with the year before,
and she was like, "I'm really
worried about the swim in."
And I said, "Oh, I go,
Don't worry about this."
And she goes, "Yeah, I'm worried about
a wave coming over,
hitting me in the head."
And I go, "Honey, That
is never gonna happen."
(laughs)
- I start swimming in,
which is like, you know
it's towards the end and
you know how you gi- going
feels like I'm not really moving anywhere.
And the next thing you know,
just as I had that thought
a wave came over and smashed
me so hard in the head.
Goggles go off, my body
is going everywhere.
And I think to myself,
"Huh, this is how I die."
- I have had this moment
with a big, huge we-
they, the waves kept coming in
and in Hawaii and I was like
they're not- the universe is
not taking this day from me.
I had like one day.
- I got really calm. Did you get calm?
- [Kelly] I got so calm!
- Yeah.
- Because I remembered that
somebody said a long time ago
that you're supposed to
get really calm and just
let your body naturally float up
[Beth] Oh that's good to know
-and quit fighting it. Yeah.
- Yeah. I just got- I got real calm.
I- I don't know if it was that
or if I was just like "All right."
(audience laughs)
- [Max] It's been great!
- This is why I ride
horses, don't do the ocean!